so I'm gonna start talking today about
um why we care about graph theory in
computational biology is probably the
starting point of all this and I'm
really starting from the OSA the 347
miles view view because I think our
field is evolving in a way that has most
recently happened to the field of
astronomy I think that's a perfect
illustration of what's going on and you
know astronomy in the last hundred years
or so has really undergone a sea change
that I would call a bit of an evolution
because it's a response to the change in
the environment that's improved proving
well maybe not survival but survival
researchers certainly survival of dances
and the idea is that in the last hundred
years or so their ability to just get
new data of a kind that you've just
never seen before you know we can put
satellite with telescope on it three
hundred and forty seven miles up there
and we can get a perspective on things
that we've never had and that's led to a
sea change and I think the same kind of
thing is happening much more recently
now in biology with the advent of things
like PCR and sequencer you know
next-generation sequencing all of a
sudden this field is really transformed
and so we can start to talk about things
in a very different way we can start to
do biology in a very different way right
we now can look we get lots more data as
the whole world is getting and now we
can start to look at things as whole
systems kind of holistically and talk
about how different parts of them work
together and relate to each other in
different ways you know so this thing is
from a group in the UK so it doesn't
suit it's not surprisingly looks like a
London subway map but it's actually a
metabolic pathway map right and somebody
drew this thing to sort of give you a
whole sense of hey this is a whole
system working together and we can look
at how the pieces of it function we get
proteins that work as parts of subunits
of molecular machines really a whole
bunch of them work together to do a
process and so we can start to look at
these questions about
do they work and how do we understand
them so what I'm actually gonna do today
is at least in this first talk is start
out by just talking about some you know
basics really want to focus I love what
Ron said earlier in the week about
representation because I think that is
such a crucial issue to the use of
networks in biology and I think we're
not thinking about it enough so I want
to talk a little about that and then I
will talk about network or graph
properties mostly with an idea people
here know graph theory mostly what I'm
going to talk about is network
properties that we might care about and
what they have to say about biology
right so what can we learn about biology
from looking at things as graphs
networks and then I'm going to talk a
little about random graph models you
know and again looking primarily at what
can they teach us about biology so
hopefully that will be at the right
level so the first question is okay we
like to talk about systems and there are
a lot of ways of talking about systems
right we could draw us a little London
subway maps about everything we could
make pictures like this so why do we
talk about systems so often in terms of
graph theory and I'm gonna draw pictures
today mostly of undirected graphs there
are directed versions some in some cases
we care about Direction mostly about
when we're representing things like
information flow in some cases we will
have weighted edges but mostly I'm going
to draw undirected graphs in lists we
specifically talk about other things
right and when we do this in biology we
get vertices that represent a range of
different things right so the most
common thing in the mostly going to talk
about today really is having vertices as
molecules so
whether they're genes or proteins or
rnase or sometimes we even talk about
drug molecules as being part of the
proteins in a graph but there's there
are a lot of other things you can
represent here right we can represent
diseases as nodes I actually think it's
really interesting we start looking at
individuals in a study as the nodes of a
graph right so we have not been doing a
lot with the growth of biomedical data
that's coming out there but imagine you
could you could come up with a graph
that you know has all the people who
have ever posted on YouTube about their
toddlers development right and you know
a couple of quotes or characteristics
that they have in common represent an
edge and then you might learn some
really interesting things about like for
example if you did this with autism you
would have found out probably by looking
at clusters in the graph and looking at
keywords associated with them you might
have seen the association between autism
and digestive disorders years before the
doctors finally figured this out all the
parents knew right the doctors didn't
know that there was a connection there
right so you can see connections like
that I'm figuring if I by thinking of
new ways to represent data and graphs
and sometimes we even have nodes that
mean different things in the same graph
and I will talk about that a little bit
but the edges are you know in whatever
it is you're doing the edges are gonna
represent some kind of relationship
between pairs of entities and I want to
kind of come back to this right so I'll
just you know the kinds that we see most
often in this field are protein protein
physical interactions where they
actually bind to each other genetic
interactions they don't necessarily bind
to each other right the definition the
classic definition of a genetic
interaction is that you cannot predict
the phenotype of mutating both proteins
from the phenotypes of mutating either
one right so classic example in yeast
you knock out this protein yeast is fine
you knock out this protein they used is
fine you knock them both out it dies
obviously hard to do this in humans and
even inappropriate to do it on large
scale and any kind of larger mental
organisms but you can predict these
kinds of things we talked a lot about
regulation yesterday so you can
represent regulatory networks tend to be
represented with direct
Edge's is you're regulating the
expression of another protein so there's
a direction to that signaling is the
same kind of thing there may be physical
interactions there may be intermediate
molecules they're not necessarily
represented in here so there is some
hidden nodes potentially and we won't
talk a lot about gene Co expression but
people do build graphs showing when
genes are expressed in the same
circumstances we'll talk a little about
that right so maybe the big question
here is when we want to represent
systems first of all why are we talking
to graphs all right I mean you know
things work in sets maybe we should be
looking at other kinds of
representations and it isn't always
clear that a graph is the right solution
right but there are subsets of problems
where we've found that binary
interactions are sufficient to give us a
lot of information and so that that kind
of question is the first thing you
really need to be asking yourself this
week you know why am I doing this and do
I need a graph is a graph the right
thing another important question I think
we should look at is you know when we're
doing a representation right we need to
think a little about how we're
representing it so maybe I should just
ask this question right or biological
networks sparse or dense networks
typically generalizing broadly sparse
right we probably don't have a protein
interacting with all other proteins we
probably don't have a person who has you
know something that we're characterizing
in common with 80% of the other people
out there because we do we probably
don't want to see those edges in a graph
anyway right it's gonna look unreadable
so when I talk about graphs we're
probably representing things with edge
lists but we can think about it in terms
of the matrix and the reason for this is
you may want to talk about spectral
decomposition of a matrix or something
else at that sorry it doesn't matter how
we're representing it you can still
characterize things this way so I'll
give a couple of examples of different
kinds of
nodes and representations where we have
sort of heterogeneous graphs this was
actually really interesting paper that I
will come back to that looks at
relationships between basically diseases
and genes and right and you can build a
graph showing edges between them and you
can infer from that a gene gene graph
that says we linked to genes if they're
if they have a disease in continent or a
disease disease graph that goes the
other way right so you can find patterns
in all of them by building something
that's bipartite and identify
relationships row dead is going to talk
a little later about this approach where
all of the nodes in bipartite graphs are
the same thing they're proteins but the
edges are actually different and there
are different kinds of edges and by
finding groups of edges you can actually
predict genetic interactions between
pairs of proteins just by looking at
where you would expect to see a genetic
interaction from from the graph
structure and you can even get
information by having different thing
you know different representations of
different kinds of nodes in the same
kind of graph without that kind of
structure right so you might have a
multi-part tie graph you might not this
is an old paper of ours we looked at
correlation and gene expression across a
set of cell lines with drug sensitivity
across the same set of cell lines and we
just sort of built a kho-kho expression
or sensitivity Network and one of the
you know one of the things we were able
to do was find subnets that had both
genes and drugs in them and predict so
actually this drug is known for working
in kitten cancers where that protein is
highly expressed and it was conjectured
as well that that wasn't other ones that
didn't really have any na and nobody
really knew what they were would
actually work and they did some testing
on that and pursuing it so you can learn
things from throwing things into a graph
even if they're kind of mixed together
and maybe the last question you want to
think about a little bit is how
biological networks that you're working
with are gonna change right so you may
actually want to be modeling evolution
or you may not want to model evolution
you may just want to figure out our
networks you know changing during the
course of the experiment in sometimes
there's some time
temporal way that they might be doing
right if you're looking at co-expression
over time for example and the bigger
question about that
is really this one right so I think
mostly the protein interaction Network
let's say of an organism is not changing
over time but what's actually happening
in that organism is and the big question
that we tend not to talk about it's kind
of the elephant in the room is what are
we missing
right what don't we know about the
graphs that we have and so most of the
graphs that we have in any biological
system that I can think of we know some
of the nodes and some of the edges and
the fact that we don't know them in that
we have bias in what we're selecting is
really crucial to understanding what's
going on so I will get back to a little
of that
so since I'm think talking about the
elephant in the room right so this is
the standard sort of you can get
different properties by looking at
different parts of the graph or
different aspects of the graph but
you're not necessarily going to get a
whole picture so it's important if
you're looking at specific network
properties to bear in mind that there's
a whole elephant out there that you may
not be seeing all of it so one of the
characteristics that we talk about a lot
with in graph theory that we will use in
biology is the degree distribution of a
graph right so it's pretty
straightforward I think just a in this
case a histogram or a frequency
histogram of the degrees of all the
nodes you could do this with in an out
degree and this can be used to
characterize any kind of network I you
know we've looked at social networks web
pages I actually really like this one
because the is and B Board of Directors
is somewhere out here and I think we've
been arguing that it ought to go that
way so I really like this picture that
shows that most companies tend to go a
little smaller right I can I'm not gonna
say I mean again I'm not gonna really
define or I'm putting up definitions of
graph theory terms but I think most
people here are pretty familiar with
them so I'm not gonna belabor that point
I'm gonna talk more about their use in
biology but I did want to just sort of
get everybody on the same page about
path lengths right so again in an
undirected graph it's just is there a
path of length of so many notes the path
length is the number of edges and we can
compute shortest paths using really your
favorite shortest path algorithm and if
we do that we get so the thing I wanted
to say about network diameter people do
talk a lot about network diameters in
biology I have seen some papers out
there that don't define it this way this
is the standard definition the longest
shortest path between any two nodes in
the graph there are people who define
diameter as the average shortest path
um I'd just be careful of that when
you're reading papers in this field but
you need to know what they're actually
talking about all right so the the first
sort of non-trivial property that I
think is really interesting for
biological networks is probably the
clustering coefficient for those of you
who didn't live through the eighties
these are brat pack actors and they have
an edge between them if they did a movie
together and most of them did movies
together but not all of them right so
this is sort of a measure of how you
know are my friends connected to my
other friends and this is a common thing
in social networks we have lots of
friends who are all connected to each
other so formally you can define that
right the clustering coefficient is so
do I have are my two friends or any two
friends of mine connected to each other
right Here I am and here are my two
friends so if they're connected and I
they're my friends then there's a
triangle right so we do this by triangle
counsel basically how many if I wanted
to the clustering coefficient this guy I
asked how many triangles there are that
are connected to this guy and I divide
that by how many possible triangles
there could be well how many could there
be it's the number of ways of choosing
all pairs of neighbors of the graph so
if I have degree of V neighbors its
degree of V times degree of EI minus one
over two right and so that's the
clustering coefficient of a node and
then you can just average that over the
whole graph to get the clustering
coefficient of the graph right so if I
have a high clustering coefficient I
look like the brat pack more or less so
why do I care about clustering
coefficient
well this turns out to have some
correlation with protein function right
and these are these are often the case
that we're looking at examples of
networks where if we have a protein
protein interaction Network and it have
and a particular node has a higher
clustering coefficient maybe that's
going to say something about how it
works right so maybe the first thing I
have to do is define the concept of
essentiality although we did talk a
little about it earlier but an essential
protein right is one that's necessary
for life so traditionally again you you
demin
straightness by knocking it out and
showing that you can't produce an
organism we don't do this in humans so
we learn this about essentiality this is
a slide about yeast but we've a lot of
the papers that I've seen that talk
about essential proteins and humans
actually look at the knockout phenotypes
in mice right you can tell development
and often they're there
proteins that are essential at some
stage in development so if you could
knock down its function later in life
when you have an adult Mouse it might be
okay but if you knock it out and and
create an embryo that way it's not going
to develop properly right so pretty much
for you know the mouse genome database
at this point has a categorization of
phenotypes for an awful lot of
perturbations of mouse genes I won't say
everything but they're they're getting
close to the point where you can look at
almost everything and sometimes they do
temperature-sensitive mutants so you can
tell what happens you know when you
disable the protein at a particular
point so what we what they discovered is
that clustering coefficient of a node is
particularly correlated with a nodes
being an essential node right right so
this sort of makes sense if all of my
friends are connected to each other I'm
doing something that's pretty pretty
well connected maybe it's pretty
important to life and they're seeing
that they actually we're also looking at
those proteins that were mediating the
toxicity you know response to a toxic
environment and there's actually we're
not quite as highly connected as the
class the essential proteins
right I am gonna comment at length about
okay so that's a great question can I
talk about essentiality in degree and
I'm there's a whole thing on this so yes
essentiality and sensuality but
basically right so there's this um well
let me do that there's there's a sort of
sensuality lethality hypothesis let me
talk about sensuality and then we'll go
there okay so what does it mean to be
central in the network right having a
high clustering coefficient is kind of
one approach to that right my net my
neighbors are all really highly
connected to each other but there are a
lot of ways of measuring how central you
are and centrality is some in some ways
a notion of importance so again it's
kind of correlated with function right
the simplest thing you could do is talk
about degree centrality raters are
basically just a normalized version of
the degree of the node this didn't seem
to me to be that exciting but actually
you know people do this and you know for
some things that works pretty well right
this this node has high degree
centrality and these guys don't on the
other hand for these other two graphs
there's something really important about
the notion of what it means to be
central in those graphs that is not
captured by the degree right so in this
bottom one the three middle nodes all
have the same degree centrality but
they're not all equally central in my
view and up there you know these guys
are actually considered more central
than this so well it depends right
they're more connected but not really
more central so one of the things that
sort of a good observation is degree
centrality is not a great measure of
kind of global properties right it's
very local and so it may be good for
measuring local properties of the area
but it's not a great way of saying okay
I care about getting information from
one side of the graph to the other or
how to communicate with people further
away closeness centrality might get at
that a little bit right so if you just
measure things by how far you know
what's sort of the length of the
shortest path to every other node and
then average that
you'll get a better sense that the node
in the middle is really more central
sometimes people will look at closeness
centrality of nodes in maybe a protein
network or a patient network related to
the clustering coefficient we have
things like eigenvector centrality right
so again it's sort of if my this is like
a variant on PageRank if my neighbors
are highly ranked or they have a lot of
edges coming in to them and then I'm
more important and that's sort of
another way of measuring that this one
is kind of good right because it's it's
saying this node is really more
important even you know because I have a
lot of neighbors that are also highly
connected so that is some I've sometimes
seen that used but the most commonly
won't used one that I've seen is
actually between this and that's really
looking at information flow so that's a
global property of the network and it is
looking specifically at for all pairs of
shortest paths in the network what
fraction of those shortest paths go
through a particular node right so this
gets at this concept if you're looking
at a network is really some way of
modeling how information moves from one
point to another
that's exactly getting at this is the
something with high betweenness is going
to have a lot of paths passing through
it and just to compare that with like a
degree centrality picture right you can
I've colored these these guys have the
same these guys are the same between the
centrality but they have different
degrees but that actually makes sense
because in terms of conducting
information between different nodes of
the graph they're actually no different
from each other right it doesn't matter
that some of these have you know one
node coming into them and some of them
have two they're still not on a path
from anything to anything else right and
so that's really capturing the
information flow more effectively
right so we can officially again I'm not
going to talk a lot about algorithms
here because you can basically use
floyd-warshall or anything any of your
favorite algorithms and because in this
particular case most of the graphs were
doing this on our protein interaction
graphs where the number of nodes is tens
of thousands and the number of edges is
not hugely bigger maybe it's hundreds of
thousands it's not huge right and so the
running time of the algorithm is
actually less of an issue than the time
it takes to implement it right or
something with that l or the meeting
constant so it's really not worth it to
try to say okay I can get my v cubed
algorithm down to 2.8 or something by
doing something really clever and
sophisticated that's going to take me
three weeks to program that may change
when we talk about other problems right
so in this particular case again I'm
leaning away from algorithms because
because the standard ones are fine so
again we can compute a number of
shortest paths why do we care about
between this why do we care about
sensuality right again this is
correlated very heavily with properties
of nodes in the network and so maybe the
classic example is some work out of
markers Dean's lab that talks about
network bottlenecks basically
bottlenecks or nodes with high
centrality some of them have also have
high degree some of them do not have
high degree there's a bottleneck that's
not a very high degree right this might
be a bottom like there is but one of the
things that he noticed was that it
mattered whether you were talking about
information flow or not right so in the
regulatory network the bottlenecks were
much more likely to be essential
molecules
in the protein interaction Network he
didn't find that as clearly in this data
set right the bottlenecks were not as
likely to be they're not any more likely
to be essential molecules right and so
this is starting to get the question you
were talking about about centrality and
the sensuality
so there is there is a centrality
lethality hypothesis that says the more
central you are in the network the more
likely you are to be an essential
protein this is a subject of some debate
and I will talk about where I'm not even
sure where their slides are but I'm
getting to at some point today where we
believe that and where we don't believe
that and why it's not always true in all
the data but I think this is starting to
get at some of the reasoning behind it
protein protein interaction networks are
actually modeling a couple of different
things right they're modeling groups of
proteins that work together to form a
complex and do something and they're
modeling proteins that individually
interact with each other under certain
conditions to pass a signal along right
so they're doing information flow and
non information flow and if you have
something here that's saying well
actually the information flow is what's
making these bottlenecks be essential
all right so so when they're important
for that sort of signaling they're
really crucial when there are parts of
complexes they may be essentially may
not be um we're muddying the data too
much we're mixing together a bunch of
different things and you know we don't
see this kind of effect necessarily in
the interaction network and therefore we
also don't see it as strongly in some of
the larger PPI data sets and we will
again I'm going to talk more about PPI
data sets
all right so
right so the other thing is what about
disease genes right or disease genes
more central or not and it seems like
that would make some kind of sense that
if genes are more essential for life
than when you disrupt them you know bad
things happen so even if you don't need
them maybe if they're not essential for
early development maybe if you disrupt
them you know you get later you get some
some negative effects corresponding to
disease right so it turns out that what
what these guys found because out of
Mercury dolls lab also is that the
essential protein so there were a
certain number of essential complexes
but aside from that most of the disease
genes were actually hubs in the protein
interaction Network I'm sorry we're not
hubs in the protein interaction where
they were peripheral right so why is
that well actually when you think about
it it makes a lot of sense with respect
to evolution right so if you have
something that has a deleterious effect
early in life it's not going you know
and it's not gonna make it right it's
gonna get weeded out of the system if
that happens right so if you have a
disease gene you're gonna lose mutations
in it you're not going to have that
disease process maintained in the
population but if it's peripheral then
maybe you can get away with having it
maintain in the population and the
corollary of this was that if that's the
case then disease then gene related
diseases from Vic arise from mutations
that happen after you reproduce more or
less would not look like this right they
would be more central and in fact that's
exactly what they found when they look
at cancer mutations in particular right
which yes children get cancer but by and
large these hits you later they're not
germline mutations if you look at
somatic mutations they tend to be the
central ones so when you look at the
whole graph of disease genes there's a
chunk of them that are central but those
are disproportionately involved in
things like cancer that that affect not
the germline but specific cells at some
point in the process so this centrality
issue is really important to figuring
out what what genes might be involved
difference between disease gene and
essential gene right so what they are
talking about right so it our Dahl
disease genes essential so basically no
right this is kind of what this is
saying is that I mean well but the
problem is if the disease is lethal then
we don't see it right in some sense it's
not lethal forty years later right it's
just so that's the distinction we're
making is it is it lethal early on or is
it lethal
after you've I mean from evolutions
point of view all we care about is have
you reproduced right kind of like
somebody's grandmother right you know
have you have you reproduced or not and
so evolution is gonna be looking at that
and saying well this is you know if
you're dead then it doesn't it doesn't
get maintained in the gene pool right so
that mutation is not good so it may be a
gene that causes a disorder but if it's
lethal at an early stage
we won't know about it um we don't
really characterize as diseases those
things that cause miscarriages we just
say that that pregnancy didn't work so
we tend to talk about disease genes as
things where we we can correlate them
with diseases during the normal lifespan
and with the exception of cancer in
these ten are less likely to be
essential and less likely to be central
so I think this way I want to start
talking a little about random graph
models right and again I think random
graph models are important here because
if we can match some of the graphs that
we see to random graph models we can
start to think about how they evolved or
how they developed and why they develop
that way
right so the most general random graph
model that people talk about is the
erdos-renyi model and I'm actually going
to talk I'm mentioning therefore the
first model they proposed which is not
the one that everybody reasons about
first right so there are two models that
are actually attributed to them where
you have a set of n vertices in them and
the first one is just that all possible
graphs with K edges on those n vertices
are sort of thrown into a pool and you
pick one at random with equal
probability right so this was actually
the first model attributed to them but
the one that everybody talks about
because it's easier to reason about was
also proposed by them but it was also
proposed by Gilbert oh man I got kind of
yelled at by a colleague of mine for
calling this the air dish REM the ax
model so I'm just being clear about that
right so in this case it's kind of like
the other one except that we have we
have a set of n nodes and we have some
particular probability and we choose
each node or sorry each edge with the
probability P between a pair of nodes so
the difference between these two models
is that the first model has exactly K
edges and the second model has on
average K edges but it has some
distribution right so you could have a
graph of no edges here you could have a
graph of that's complete unlikely but if
n is of any size at all but it's
possible
and the erdos-renyi model is pretty
right so I think sometimes represented
is G of N and P right so the expected
number of edges is the number of
possible edges times the probability and
the expected degree follows if you just
assume that each edge has two endpoints
so what do we want to say about arrow
Dishman you get let's see how much time
I've got one of the important things
about them is that you get a series of
phase transitions in the graphs as you
grow it so basically if you think about
it when when you have a very large end
when you're a really small probability
you're not gonna have any edges at all
all right if it's substantially less
than one over N squared you're not gonna
get any edges if it's substantially
greater than one over N squared you
expect to see some edges all right so
there's a point at an inflection point
at or a phase transition and one over N
squared where you get you know go from
not having edges to having edges and
there are similar transition points for
a sort of larger all sorts of
connectivity properties right so you can
get you know a component of size greater
than two triangles spanning trees and so
on right so when you simulate this you
can see how you kind of this is like a
phase transition on a graph with 50
nodes when P is small you just get maybe
a few edges and one component that's
larger than two right when it gets a
little bigger you start to see cycles
and a decent sized component that's
bigger than log n when you get a little
bigger you get what's called a giant
component where most of the nodes are
collected and connected in and it takes
a while to actually get to the point
where every node is connected right so
there are these sort of phase transition
points in the random graph model
the other property that people sometimes
look at is the degree distribution of
the random graph model so this is
basically a binomial distribution send
the edges write the probability of
choosing an edge so basically if you you
have the probability of having a note of
degree V V is exactly the number of
possible nodes that you could choose
ways you could choose D edges out of a
node so actually there's this should
really be n minus 1 but it depending
selfloops
so I've seen both formulations
represented and then the probability of
having those d edges and not having the
other edges right so this is binomial
it's actually close to Poisson and as
large you can approximate it with by the
Poisson distribution so these are
sometimes called Poisson random graphs
right so the big question that we run
into is our biological networks like
this and some may be right you can look
at a number of the properties we've
discussed of these graphs and try to say
do they look more like this or not but a
lot of biological networks and a lot of
natural networks of all kinds don't look
like this many of them have this sort of
power law distribution where when you
look at it on a log-log plot you get
more or less a straight line
approximating that right so these are
also called scale free graphs where the
probability is proportional to of having
something of degree K is proportional to
K to the negative alpha for some alpha
often alphas between 2 and 3 for a lot
of natural networks for some reason all
right and so we see this for many kinds
of biological graphs one of the
important things about these kind of
graphs
is looking at fault-tolerance properties
right so in so this is sort of an
example on the right here we have a
random graph model of network of
distribution across the the US maybe
maybe interested a highway network looks
a little more like this right and it's a
system where you know if you if you
knock out a particular betray node it's
more likely to have sort of average
connectivity so you're going to do a
reasonable amount of damage but if you
you know so it's but there aren't any
particular nodes where you could say
well I'm going to do the you know a huge
amount of damage so I'm gonna get that
one in something with a power-law
distribution you get the emergence of
what are called hubs right nodes of high
degree and if you have hubs that are
particularly high degree and most node
have particularly low degree then you're
really robust to random failures but
you're particularly able to handle I'm
sorry you're not particularly able to
handle malicious attacks alright so if I
want to do damage I'm going to knock
this guy out but you know and this is
the way the web works right by and large
random failures don't you know nobody
notices them because by and large they
effect some relatively not very
connected part of the web if a major hub
goes down that's a problem but it's
unlikely to happen at random it's gonna
take a conservative the attack right so
again we care about this somewhat in the
concept of
biological networks so again most the
protein interaction networks certainly
do look hubby right they look more like
power law graphs sort of they definitely
have a number of hubs and this talks
about evolution as well right so the
hubs tend to evolve a lot of connections
and stay that way no nodes tend to be
have been shown to be older
evolutionarily right and because in
addition they are more essential
proteins right so the hub nodes tend to
be considered essential this
vulnerability to random attack can be
used for a bunch of ways so this is
actually some stuff looking at protein
interactions between host proteins and
viruses right if you have a viral so
viruses don't have a lot of genes of
their own or a lot of proteins of their
own and so they tend to work by
co-opting proteins from the host right
so you get viral proteins that interact
with host proteins in order to infect
the host and reproduce the virus which
isn't skull so what happens is that
viral proteins can survive right so this
is actually the kind of situation where
you have a malicious attack in the sense
that the host organism is trying to
evolve a way that the virus protein
can't interact with it right so the host
is trying to break that down and the
virus is trying to maintain it so what
tends to happen is one of two things
either you get in virus interacting with
very highly connected host proteins
where it's hard to get rid of this
because if you change that one protein
you're gonna have to change
you know we're effect of a large highly
connected Network or it affects
interacts with a large number of not so
connected proteins and so again you
could change one of them but in order to
break this you're gonna have to change a
whole lot of things right so this is the
sort of thing you can learn about
evolutions and you can use things like
this to try to predict for
in protein interactions with button
between viruses and hosts and therefore
ideally designed drugs that interfere
with it or something with that at ELQ so
there are real corollaries to some of
these properties what are the two is
more so actually both of those tend to
happen and again we this is just data
that looked at HIV right so getting
getting data for protein and viral virus
host interactions on a comprehensive
enough scale to do this is actually this
is older older results there might be
more data now on this but it was not
something that was done that
systematically for that many viruses but
HIV they pretty well characterized the
interactions of and it really does both
so it depends on the viral protein there
were some that do this and there's
something to do that but they tend to be
if they're interacting with the host
that's what they're doing and that's how
they evade I guess being disrupted and
what makes it hard to treat them
so hang on
so the last couple of models I wanted to
talk about our models that are more like
social network models they're sort of
small world models where the idea these
basically try to capture some of the
properties that you have in biological
no I'm sorry natural occurring networks
not just biological but you know social
networks or web networks or something so
basically the idea is things have high
clustering coefficient or what I said
called here's transitive friends right
my friends friends or my friends but
that's pretty common in social networks
but when you look at your Facebook graph
you don't just have a near clique of
friends you also have links to random
people you know a little bit what would
they call weak ties right you know
somebody through work you know somebody
through I don't know the trip you took
last week with a group of people from
after after at the lab you met
somebody's spouse or something and you
connected to them so you have these weak
ties and the good thing about these weak
ties is that they tend to connect to
random other parts in the network and so
they make the diameter much lower so the
diameter of small world networks is
thought to be you know typically on the
order of log n where you have n nodes
whereas a graph with height just high
clustering coefficient the diameter
could be order n or something of that
ilk so it's not just these small high
clustering coefficient but weak ties
that make this work so an example of
that is to do something they have this
sort of nice ladder ring lattice model
where you simulate this but let's say
you connect to every node in of a group
of n nodes to all of its neighbors of
distance K along the along the graph
right and then with some probability
you're gonna rewire some of those edges
so with every with probability P each
edge gets moved right you have a node
that does this and instead you break
that node and you move it over here
alright so here we have an example of
something where you have high clustering
coefficients but also these weak ties to
random parts of the network they connect
things very well and so it can be shown
that when you do this at some reasonable
size you get very nice small world
properties right you get these high
clustering coefficients but small
diameters on most such random networks
right and so this is again good for well
there are some papers that argue that in
general this is a good way to support
complex systems but particularly it's
good at making sure that you can
communicate effectively with distant
parts of the network while functioning
in a coherent way on a local scale right
so it's a property that deals with both
local and global properties and a really
nice example of this that isn't
protein-protein interaction networks was
actually modeling neural connections as
a network right and so these folks did
some work on the neural connections of a
couple of different model organisms and
we're able to demonstrate that you know
there's small world that simulations did
a nice job of connecting things in the
way that neural networks ought to be
connected and the real ones looked very
much like it so the actual connectivity
map between neurons was sort of had this
small world property right you could see
how that could be useful for building a
functioning brain right you want to be
able to fan-out the signal very quickly
when you need to but many decisions get
made locally
so
roof of this
sorry I'm going backwards there we go
right so a lot of things so the one of
the questions is how does scale-free
networks arise all right and they arise
through some sort of growth process that
I mean again you can kind of simulate
this at random but you're getting
increasing numbers of both nodes and
edges and you're getting what they call
preferential attachment basically if you
have high degree you're more likely to
have more edges coming into you so hubs
become heavier if I can use that
terminology right barabasi and Albert's
actually showed through some simulation
that this preferential attachment thing
is what makes networks have a scale-free
kind of distribution right so that's
essential you get this a lot in nature
it's basically saying that you make
local decisions and you get this kind of
global structure right so I'm just going
to decide who don't we go I'm gonna
decide where to point my webpage to do I
want to point it towards you know
respected sources that have a lot of
links already or do I want to point it
to you know my kid's best friend right
well probably I mean maybe I'll do a
little of that but mostly I'm gonna go
towards something that that's going to
increase my respect by pointing to
highly connected nodes so this is the
same kind of thing right it's a making
local decisions everybody's making local
decisions but we get as an the emergence
of this big global property from it and
so there's a question about whether you
get this in biological network evolution
as well right how do how do networks
evolve right they grow they tend to grow
often by duplication and then change
right so either you get mutation that's
kind of gradual or you get duplication
of something and it then diverges so
it's not always clear that you get this
kind I mean you get a certain kind of
preferential attachment where you have
something that if it's high degree it's
gonna continue to be high degree but
it's it's sort of debatable and the
growth model is definitely a little bit
different from what tends to effect
sorry um power law graphs that are
randomly simulated pavulon drives right
and so this is again of some debate the
last I just have a couple of minutes I
wanted to talk a little bit more about
local structure and local models so some
of the some interest has arisen from
characterizing individual Network motifs
in local graph so you can look at small
sub structures of any set of two or
three or five nodes and try to
characterize the shape of that if you do
this you can either find functions
associated with those particular shapes
or you can actually characterize the
whole graph globally again by these
local properties and one of the pieces
of that that looks kind of interesting
is this last random graph model which is
called a geometric random graph model
where basically you pick a number of
points in space uniformly at random in
some metric space and then there's an
edge between every pair of points that
are within some radius R right so one of
the things you'll notice about this very
quickly this is just a simulation I
threw together in our few days ago is
that you get you know high clustering
coefficients which you'd expect right
you're connected very tightly to your
neighbors by definition but you don't
have these weak ties so the diameter of
such networks you know to get from here
to here is actually a pretty long path
right so these I think in some ways
resemble some of the local structure of
biological networks in other ways they
may not there are some results arguing
that the graph with distribution of
these kinds of graphs is more similar to
those approaching protein interaction
networks that have been observed than
other things but I think they may also
be lacking you know if you look at other
other properties like the diameter I
think they're gonna be a little bit off
so whether these things emerge and this
is this is another way of thinking about
evolution of connections of sort of
looking at mutant maybe this is more of
a model of individual mutation rather
than duplication so maybe the real thing
is some combination of the two
actually be interesting to look at
weighted versions of combinations of the
two and see if you do a better version
of capturing than the global network
properties so that's an open problem if
somebody wants to play her element in
some metric yeah so in some metric space
so actually it's a good question um they
tried two three and four dimensional
metric spaces and three was in fact what
work best
right so but the local strata structure
you know the distribution of things that
look like that and things that look like
this was similar to what was actually
observed with the big caveat that what
we're actually observing is this subset
of data right so now we're talking about
protein interaction networks and I'm
going to talk about that again in about
an hour
but the subset of data that we're
getting is noisy in ways that we really
need to characterize this so I should
actually just end maybe with an anecdote
which is that I came into this field of
computational biology through machine
learning and I was working with Ron
Rivest on machine learning from noisy
data and how we had all these great
theoretical models of machine learning
and noise and what kinds of noise we
could have and you know very engineering
models with probabilities and good
distributions and then I stumbled into
the Human Genome Project and I thought
was a great source of noisy data which
um they get really huffy when you say
that but in fact it's true and all of
our noise models were completely wrong
right we simulate this stuff poorly we
continue to simulate it poorly because
it's real life and it doesn't follow
nice pretty engineering models of noise
except in simple cases like if we're
looking at transmission errors or
something right or storage errors but
the noise that we're actually
experiencing is is you know a living
thing and so the actual models don't
always fit your expectations
so we really need to characterizing and
understanding the source of the noise is
really important and I think we will
talk about that later and for now I'll
just say that we are being controlled by
their anima outcomes of a complex system
they nailed it better than power law and
the models or small watt Strogatz kind
of random models it's that's a good
question right I mean this is one
person's perspective it's not
necessarily mine but but they're you
know they had some interesting I think
what's interesting about it and the
reason I'm talking about it is that
there are some interesting local
properties that emerge from that sort of
style and so maybe maybe I actually
think that the real thing you know what
actually happened was some combination
of duplication and mutation and
therefore it could be represented by
something that has some probability of
looking like a random like a small world
model and some probability of looking
like a geometric model
I actually don't have good well I I mean
again local connections are probably
mutations right so I'm connected to my
neighbors so if i duplicate and mutate a
little bit or just mutated something I'm
gonna change and connect to neighbors
and a little a little bit of a
neighboring way so you know not a very
distant way I'm not gonna make these no
it's not necessarily clear right it's
possible that a small mutation makes a
huge conformational shift and then and
then you do something totally different
so that's you could argue that point but
I guess that's what the model is yeah
yeah so this is this so this was
actually a three dimensional or their
results we're three dimensional the
simulation was not the space of 3d and
there's a distant yet Euclidean distance
biological interaction the distance has
influence
let's say one
that's really close to another genius
then is it more relevant
maybe right so sometimes genes and
proteins can compensate for each other
and sometimes they don't
right and I mean is it more relevant you
know the the one you interact with is
usually often there's a region that's
complementary to yours but it's not
necessarily identical to you but within
with something within reason right so
when you have gene duplication events
within the species there may be some
propensity for interaction but often you
know they're often they share their
partners or until they diverge
sufficiently
so I haven't really followed in detail
this power law model but for a while
right
so actually in the protein-protein
interaction talk later I have I that's
where I have the slide on this but a lot
of things look like they have power law
models this you know protein interaction
networks there's a debate on this right
some of the some things look very much
with some data sets look very much like
that or a good fit to that and some
aren't and then there are all sorts of
explanations as to why so we can take
that offline for now but I will come
back to it
standing between you guys in coffees so
I think I should let you get cup